What up, welcome to the trillionaire club guys,
big deal here in the tree, in our club.
Not only are you richer than the richest man in the world,
but also you can learn about the system that helped this man obtain his Lambo in
90 days. Yes, that's right. Uh, pretty incredible stuff.
But before we get into that,
we're going to do something that I want to call ethics tips.
This is basically a lot of comments since the golden rule is don't be a piece
of. Basically. Don't lie to people,
ladies and gentlemen.
So many of you are out there just doing the most ridiculous things to try to get
clicks. You think that clicks are everything and are worth selling out for,
or compromising your image. And it's not.
Let me show you an example of what I mean today.
This is what I like to call the tick talk lie.
I really don't want to play too much of this. Otherwise,
we're going to get demonetized here, but it says a mute it, here we go.
When.
Our clients make high ticket sales without a webinar or funnel,
and you see this lady freaking out and Oh my gosh, look at them.
They're so excited because they're getting high ticket sales without a webinar
or funnel. Now somebody sent me this and they pointed out, look,
you have the coach on the left-hand side, smiling ride.
You have the family and the right-hand side, his life has been changed,
but here's the deal. It's faith. That's right guys.
Because if someone pointed out to me, someone else was doing this too.
And both of these people are lying about it.
This is the same exact video, Friday, Friday,
man. So much money. Come join my team, right?
You'll be shouting like this family right here. You'll be so excited.
But here's the deal.
This is not about anyone taking a guru's course.
This is all stolen from a tick-tock.
It says posting because I love these videos.
And this is the happiest I've been in a while for getting into my dream school.
This is this lady getting into her dream school.
And it's now being used as a reaction for marketers.
Pretending like it's their course that got them to act like this. I mean,
watch again, guys, what would you think if you saw this dude?
Oh yeah.
Ah, I'm so happy for them. Except this isn't real. This is a lie.
It's a lie. Gotcha. Look anything, dude.
These people will do anything for the sale. It's unbelievable. Don't do this.
Okay. This is bad, bad.
And then what's funny is I saw this guy who video,
we just watched talking about, Oh, how do you think I get so many testimonials?
Have you ever had.
I had an issue getting testimonials from your clients? If so,
I want you to stay tuned in this field because I'm going to show you exactly how
I get so many testimonials.
So don't worry, Tanner.
Chidester we know how you get so many testimonials.
Buddy. Yeah. You troll.
Over to that. A tick tock page.
And you just go ahead and throw it a little reaction right here.
Let's do one right now.
[Inaudible].
But anyway guys, that's the ethics tip of the day.
Don't take reactions and pretend that they're your customers.
How this, this honestly, isn't that hard,
but this ethics tip has been brought to you by our old friends over at
info Wars. You guys know I'm a media buyer for Alex. Uh,
obviously he wants to support the show, Alex,
thanks for your support of the show. I didn't even know you watched, uh,
you know, you have a message for these gurus. You're you're upset about it.
What do you have to say to them?
Lam heads with you. I'm here to take you down.
My destruction is the seeds of your shore destruction fools.
Thank you, Alex. As always,
this message has been brought to you by crippling debt for my expensive $10
million studio. Guys, you may have noticed the production value is sick lately.
Um,
I seem to be in these incredible places that I almost couldn't be physically.
And you wonder how do you put up such a gigantic studio? Well, guys, I'm in,
you should know.
I built a gigantic warehouse and all of these sets are physically built.
I'm physically in these areas and that's just what it is.
And we have to pay for it. Somehow guys, money is a fuel unit. Don't forget.
You must have enough fuel.
To live out your new Lamborghini here in the Hollywood Hills.
But anyway, guys, let's get back to it. Okay?
You want to know you're here for the trillionaire club.
You want to know how do I get a Lambo in 90 days? Well,
our boy, the Ray cart here is here to tell you.
Now the first thing to know is he's one of these lifestyle gurus. Now,
what do I mean by that?
I mean that he doesn't really talk about how to make money.
He more just shows off his lifestyle and then is always saying like, Oh,
hit me up. If you want to know more like, like pictures like this, okay?
Mind the business that pays you. Okay. I don't, what is that? Huh?
Leverage the system that pays you. Ooh, we're getting original now.
But ultimately all this money has to come from somewhere after all.
He says that he didn't start with a silver spoon in his mouth. No,
he was broke before he learned how to make this money.
Here we go from being 10 K in debt to six, figure income,
want to find out how send us a DM.
[Inaudible].
Nothing like a money counter to really get us interested. But my point is,
you really don't know what this guy's into until you kind of dig a little bit
more in, you know, all of these lifestyle guys are like that. You're like,
what do you do besides take pictures? Like, how do you make money?
It's there. You're saying you're so successful.
You're getting a Lambo in 90 days. How.
Is Ray Milano? I'm on 26 year old Forex trader and I've helped.
Thousands of people become successful in Forex trading.
Come on, dude.
Today I checked off another dream of.
Mine.
I swear, dude,
this is just bait for the 18 year olds out there who want to
get rich quick. They're watching this stuff like, Oh my gosh,
I don't need to go to college. I don't need to get a job.
I'm going to quit my whole career and go join Ray.
Cardiay cardiac care. How do you say it? I don't know.
And it's disgusting, but it's also hilarious. Like you're following this.
What is he actually selling you? Right? I can't, I still don't know.
What is he selling education. Okay. What does that mean? What did,
how did he learn to trade Forex? Okay.
So apparently a lot of this is linked to this thing.
He does called sky net legacy.
Now it says new and improved artificial intelligence trading. So I was like,
okay, that's what he does. He's an artificial intelligence trader,
which honestly sounds cooler than it actually is. You know,
there's a lot of these trading bots that make nothing.
But I was interested in what actually this is.
So I went to the page, you get some generic thing.
So I got the webinar, whatever I went to the webinar link.
Now this is where I'm doing the due diligence for you guys to have you actually
go and sign up for the webinar.
This is what you get to an unlisted YouTube video where it's selling you not
on Skynet legacy.
I thought this guy had created his own artificial intelligence.
That's what he makes it sound like. And his advertising instead,
he's pitching something called a vorea prime.
Now I'm not going to bore you with all of this. But basically he goes, Oh yeah,
we'll meet the team. You know,
it's this amazing team that built this amazing trading bot that you can use to
make money. No questions asked. This is what this guy is selling you.
He's saying you can be like me. You can be rich. If you join a vorea prime,
they sell an Alexander package and an era's package. There are two trading bots,
I guess they give you alerts. One is two 67 now one 89 a month.
And the other is $110 a month. So you're thinking,
Oh, so it's a product.
That's how people are making money or they're making money by trading. No,
also not. That's not how they make their money. This is, this is actually,
and it takes,
it took me forever to realize this it's just a multi-level marketing company.
It's all a front, it's a product. That's right at the end of the day,
after all this talk about wealth, you know, living the lifestyle,
it turns out that this is a,
an MLM and it's not even first version of this MLM.
It started as silver start live.
I don't know if you guys can see that silver star live right here,
which apparently ended in a $75,000 fraud settlement.
Then they tried rebooting it as EA economy that collapsed.
Now they're rebooting it again under this guy. Now,
does that guy look familiar to you?
He should because that's this man right here, Sal Lettow.
He's one of the guys that marketed the one coin Ponzi scheme.
And now he's trying to revamp this failed trading bot as
Avorio prime. This is all according to behind MLM,
which I find to be a pretty reputable source.
When it comes to investigating these types of opportunities. Now,
what does this all mean? Well, it means basis is safe. I mean,
I really thought when I saw the trillionaire club up here that bayzos has been
cracked. I mean, as you know, he's not a trillionaire yet.
He's probably watched this guy like, Hey, do I have to take this guy out?
I have to drone strike him. He's is he ahead of me in the game? I'll know this.
Guy's another poser trying to sell you with jealousy with, uh,
envy. He's trying to sell you a product and make himself rich.
And he's trying to sell you. Multi-level marketing guys. What are we in 2012,
dude, I thought this Avon Amway stuff was long dead.
Apparently it's all moved over to us. Stuff like Forex, stuff like that.
Don't bother with this stuff, guys.
You should know by now you should know better. We here in the cup,
these L army were advanced in the game.
So if you ever see one of your friends getting into this stuff, Hey, stop them.
You got to tell them, look, friends. Don't let friends get in scams. That's it.
By the way, also, let me just say as an aside, if you can avoid,
I know a lot of people are super into cars,
but the more you can avoid getting trapped by
these and they are a trap, uh,
kind of like luxury desires, the less you have to work. I mean,
all these people, they always talk about like living a laptop lifestyle,
you know,
the best way to live a laptop lifestyle and to not have to work as much lower
your expectations. If you want to Lambo, Hey, guess what?
You're going to be working hard. I'm work at busting it all the time.
Just so you can have other dudes can look at you like nice car, bro.
But instead, if you can just be content, you know, with the Honda civic.
But instead that sounds so lame, but you guys know what I mean. If you,
if you don't have to have all that stuff, guess what?
You don't need to work as hard because you don't have these like crazy
expectations for life.
That's why I think these things are doubly stupid because on the one hand it
promotes like this like, Oh dude, Hey bro, just.
Gab cash and stacks. And then live.
This luxury lifestyle. And you have kids like idolizing this stuff,
which is so stupid. But then at the same time,
they don't make the money that they're saying you need to make to the lifestyle.
So they're promoting this super expensive lifestyle and also not delivering.
Sorry to get all philosophical with you boys. That's basically it.
Thanks for watching.
Don't forget to smash like and subscribe. Thank you.
[inaudible].